hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video schalte ich hoffe
natürlich wäre es gut an die die sich
immer wegen dem mikrofon aufbringen weil
es ja immer so halter oder so ihr wisst
was ich meine
ich habe mir jetzt einen anstrich
vorgestellt hat ist besser glaube ich
dann steht das hier auch nicht mal so
dumm rum
naja ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut
wir machen heute folgendes und zwar habe
ich ein neues produkt ich hab mir
gedacht das wär super schade wenn wir
uns das nicht einmal genauer anschauen
weil ich auch weiß dass viele sich von
euch dafür interessieren ist schon ein
bisschen länger hält sich das bestellt
habe ich kann sich hier super gerne mal
zeigen so saßen
genau hier haben wir das gute stück
drahtlose bluetooth 5.0 kopfhörer für
nur 10 euro
also das ist wirklich schon sehr günstig
ihr seht ihr es handle sich um airport
profi und der versandhändler sechs euro
kosten also insgesamt 16 euro trotzdem
super günstig ich weiß ja nicht roma 1
bei uns bestellt habe da habe ich
bestimmt
auf jeden fall über 35 wenn nicht sogar
über 40 euro bezahlt also die meisten
die solche fakes verkaufen da passt auf
40 euro für das ding ist wenn wir hier
draufgehen den artikel gibt's nicht mehr
aber ich habe den gefunden also den gibt
es aber noch nicht unter diesem link
warum auch immer ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass das hier der artikel war den
ich bestellt habe hier heißen die dann
40 r pro 3 das ist sowieso immer ein
halbes durcheinander die einen die dann
so die anderen so aber auch hier kann
man sehen dass dingen kostet nur 12 euro
62 es etwas gibt es da so asset preise
aber gut ist anscheinend neu stand von 8
euro ich habe noch mal weniger bezahlt
also hier sind wir knapp 20 das müsste
das produkt sein sieht eigentlich ganz
schön aus gab es in verschiedenen farben
ich habe das in weiß bestellt schauen
wir uns ganz lange die bewertung ansieht
halbwegs gut aus ich habe sie für meine
kids geholt und die mögen sie man muss
aber natürlich auch ganz klar sagen 16
euro
da kann man jetzt nicht dass heftigst
erwarten ich bin ja eigentlich profi auf
dem gewesen wir haben schon viel
ausgepackt und ich kann mir schon ein
bisschen ausmalen was hier drin sein
wird oder was das produkt für eine
qualität aber vielleicht werde ich auch
überrascht wer weiß
ich hab natürlich schon einmal angeguckt
weil ich das ganze material verrückt ich
versichere euch wir haben in dem paket
einfach nur diese kopfhörer gerade
momente kabel war auch dabei ich weiß
nicht ob ihr euch daran erinnert ich
habe mich schon mal ausgepackt in dem
video was nur so produkte aber die haben
ja nicht reingepasst kabeln wohlig kurz
sonst wenn ich euch sehr gerne mal den
ausschnitt hier ein die haben das auch
schon also diese beiden sachen waren da
drinnen mehr nicht keine beschreibung
keine verpackung ist halt einfach zehn
euro
ok dann ziehen wir dir mal schön diese
blaue folie habt warum auch immer die
darum ist also das hätte man sich doch
eigentlich auch sparen können aber gut
ok also hier haben wir die dinger ich
muss wirklich sagen ich hatte schon
viele fakes in der hand auch die
original natürlich die ich jetzt nicht
hier habt die sind auf jeden fall ein
bisschen leichter aber erst sagen du
bist gar nicht so schlecht kann das hier
mal raus
ich habe mich nämlich gerade schon
gewundert
ja das ist nämlich das was ich mir
gedacht habe wobei die sogar grün
leuchten diesmal sonst hatten wir ja
immer vielleicht erinnert durch strand
diese ganzen airports erste und zweite
generation flechsig ausgepackt habe die
billigsten vom billigsten hamid war so
blau rot beleuchtet und hier haben wir
das jetzt auch hier unten leuchten die
blau jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr haben
sie gerade aber und hier oben hat grün
ich habe jetzt gerade tatsächlich noch
andere fakes gefunden die haben glaube
ich 42 euro damals gekostet und da hier
bekommt man die stets über hintendrauf
designed by apple in california könnt
ihr jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht sehen ich
aber und hier bei dem zehn euro fällt
nicht drauf und die haben wir fordern
auch diese kleine lampe die fehlt hier
auch aber gut
ja die blinken so schön grün immer so
gleichzeitig dann komm erstmal zum
soundcheck ich bin gespannt was sie zehn
euro länger koenigsegg kurz die manie
connected weil das war ja immer
unterschiedlich mal schauen will
angezeigt ja das sind ohne mich hier
stets das werden die seien erst froh
hessen am ende doch warum eigentlich
nicht erst pro 3 dann stelle ich mir
jetzt mal ins ohr
wir haben hier auch diese schwarze
markierung diese auch beim original wird
ach so moment mal das ding ist die
laufen hat jetzt schon also die erkennen
nicht wenn sie im ohr sind und wann
nicht also denke ich die mal einen
moment okay wir haben hier natürlich
kein neues cancelling aber dadurch dass
diese tropfen so tief im ohr sind
schützen die eigentlich schon ganz gut
vor dem scheibe von außen kommen also
schon meine stimme nicht so gut wie wenn
ich jetzt einfach meine airports zweiter
generation im ohr hauptstadt war bin ich
wieder zum betrunken und die dritten
zähne alter hey leute ich weiß nicht ob
es daran liegt weil ich lange sowas
nicht mehr getestet aber die sind echt
also für 10 16 euro
hammer gut ich muss mal ganz kurz einmal
noch die hier ins ohr stecken ob die
auch so gut war ich glaub's nicht also
wie gesagt ich meine die haben 42 kostet
ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau auf
jeden fall waren die deutlich teurer als
die hier sehen vom ding ja auch
eigentlich genauso aus
ich muss wirklich sagen die sind die
haben mich gerade um diese zehn euro
dinger das ist einfach kassen wie
schnell sich dieses geschäft davon
entwickelt die werden billiger die
qualität oder die soundqualität nimmt
deutlich zu dass du hier manchmal grün
blinken ist bisschen weg aber ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich könnte euch dann
kann ich schon empfehlen ich für zehn
euro kann man sich da wirklich nicht
beschweren ich verlinke ihr euch einfach
sehr gerne mal in der video beschreibung
was halt nur ein bisschen scheiße usd
laufen halt wirklich immer also du
verbindest du ein handy
damit und schon spielt die musik darüber
ab ob wurde die nicht mehr am ohr hast
aber gut also mein fazit
daumen hoch das wird jetzt in zukunft
öfter videos geben wo ich einfach nur
ein tolles produkt vorstelle dann meine
meinung dazu sagen und dann gibt es halt
vielleicht mehr videos weil ich die
erfahrung gemacht haben dass manchmal
den videos viele leute sich nur für ein
produkt haben oder interessieren dann
nehme ich halt die wir einfach die
sachen die kurs- und zeigte dann halt in
einem video was dann zwar ein bisschen
kürzer ist dafür hatte ich mir im bus
auf einen haufen und ich hoffe dass wir
das auch beim cool finden wir sehen uns
dann morgen schon wieder um 19 uhr gibt
es ein neues video hat gerne gegen einen
kommentar schreibt euren unserem namen
dazu und dann suche ich irgendwann wenn
aus dem ich die zu schicken weil ich die
selber halt nicht benutze ich habe
natürlich nicht vergessen dass auch noch
die mechanisch ps 4 verlost wird das
werde ich auf jeden fall im nächsten
teil von den research products auflösen
werde bekommt also keinen stress mitteln
und youngster morgen haut rein abonniert
eigenen kanal und sie verkehrt